the shaky science show clips
um and so obviously the the base editing
has given us a massive toolkit then but
in terms of the actual editing it's
still obviously any um a base editing
even with multiplexing it's just editing
a specific basis and so obviously in
terms of precision genome editing
there's still the kind of search for
being able to make larger scale dynamic
changes that we have control over
instead of forming indels and so um i
think that kind of nicely leads on to
prime editing and
what prime editing is and how what kind
of challenges it was trying to solve
right yeah so um
to to fill in that that story i think
it's a great segue
you know so the
alexis comore led uh cytosine base
editor
can only make two kinds of dna changes
it can change c's into ts and g's into
a's
and so our first effort to really
broaden the applicability of
precise gene genome editing without
double stranded breaks was to develop a
different kind of base editor an adenine
based editor
which can change a's into g's and t's
into c's so it actually does the
opposite of what a cytosine base editor
does
that just by
uh
because of the nature of human gene
mutations that adenine base editor turns
out to be
the most useful kind of single base pair
uh
corrector if your goal is to correct
mutations that are responsible for
pathogenic
uh changes in in cells for diseases
so about half of
uh pathogenic disease point mutations
are caused by
uh the kind of base pair change that is
fixed with an adenine base editor
and so on so nicole godelli a former
postdoc in the lab now at beam
therapeutics
developed this adenine base editor that
changes
at base pairs to gc base pairs
and there the project was um
you know i give her a lot of credit
because uh the the key enzyme to
deaminate adenine in dna
wasn't known
there was no known and there still is no
known naturally occurring
reported enzyme that will
deaminate adamine into inosine in dna
and so nicole
agreed to take the brave step of
evolving her own enzyme
as the starting material for this
project
uh even though in general in our lab we
we stay away from projects where step
one is evolve
a starting material because it sort of
sounds like two significant projects not
one
and so after a lot of hard work she she
did
manage to evolve the first enzyme
to our knowledge that can
deaminate adenine in dna and convert it
into a base that
pairs like g
and then we could install that
new deaminase that nicole evolved into a
base editing architecture and then that
led to the adenine base editor
and then we've further evolved it which
uh led to these uh super active variants
like abe8e
and that's the variant that
we and others are now seeing
consistently uh at some sites in certain
kinds of cells um
uh you know more than 90 editing
but but even with the cytosine-based
editors that alexis developed and the
admin base editor is that nicole
developed that's only four kinds of base
to base changes
and of course simple math will tell you
because there's four different dna
letters and you can change each letter
to three other kinds that means there's
12
total ways you can mutate one base to
another base so
the eight remaining mutations which are
called transversions
we could not make with base editing at
least not not efficiently and directly
and of course there are a large number
of insertions and deletions uh
the vast majority of which are small
fewer than 10 or 20 bases
that are associated with really
important genetic diseases like cystic
fibrosis and taste sex disease
so
uh so it's been a i think a
long standing goal of the group since we
started working with base editors to
figure out
a way to directly install those other
kinds of base to base changes
and to install deletions or insertions
again without making double stranded
breaks
and that led to the development of of
prime editing which can achieve those
goals in
a million cells so prime editing really
began also with a prospective group
member
a prospective postdoc named andrew
anzalone
who applied to the lab
he's a former md phd student at columbia
he worked with virginia cornish
who was a former lab mate of mine when i
was a grad student in peter schultz's
lab virginia was a postdoc in the lab
anyhow virginia recommended andrew
strongly and and
when he came to the lab at the end of
his meetings with various people
um you know i have a one-on-one meeting
with him right before he gives his
group meeting talk
and i
asked him the usual questions um you
know what other labs are you interested
in uh
what kinds of projects do you envision
working on
what's the time frame of your
desired postdoc et cetera
and when i asked him what are you
thinking of working on
he pulled out
this
kind of audacious idea
that that he had written up into a slide
basically
which
proposed that perhaps we could use um
a reverse transcriptase to directly copy
this
an edited dna sequence from
the extent from an extension on a guide
rna
into a nicked target dna site
and you know it was a wild idea and
there were all sorts of reasons why it
might have failed
it really took a confluence of
you know but at the time we called small
miracles but now i think just
uh to be
to be more accurate but was just a
reflection of the hard work of andrew
and co-workers to overcome
uh but i was excited enough by the idea
that
i asked me to do something i normally
don't ask prospective postdoc to do
which is why don't you present that idea
at the end of your
your postdoc seminar
so he gave his group meeting seminar
about his phd work and at the end
he
put in a slide on his idea
and
you know as you might imagine the
the lab found it really interesting but
was also very skeptical about all sorts
of various pieces of it
including the fact that
when you nick dna
and you put on edited dna you have to
figure out the cell to figure out what
to do with that edited dna flap which is
now redundant with the non-edited
sequence that's still on the dna double
helix ahead of that nick
and
even if that edited dna flap somehow
somehow ends up sitting down on dna
you now have a heteroduplex where one
strand is edited one strand is not
edited but the edited strand the one you
care about was recently nick
so isn't that going to be preferentially
removed by mismatch repair
etc
the answer to all those questions
actually turns out to be yes but uh it
still works
um
so uh to make a long story short andrew
started in a test tube where we like to
start out since where uh our group has
uh
has is historically made of chemists and
we have strong chemistry ties so we like
to start out in a test tube where we can
control and analyze things easier
uh his idea seems to be plausible in a
test tube and a test to you if you
showed that
a cas9 nick case plus a reverse
transcriptase
plus a guide rna with a reverse
transcript based template added to its
three prime or five prime end
could template reverse transcription of
the nicked target dna site and he ran
all the proper controls to show that
these weren't artifacts
and then he tried this in yeast cells
and it worked quite well in east
which was starting to get interesting
however yeast are addicted to all sorts
of dna repair processes that
are very difficult to do in humans
such as
homologous recombination which is really
easy to do in yeast
but very difficult to do in humans in
fact yeast prefer to make
homologous recombination products over
indels in many in many cases in response
to double stranded breaks whereas the
opposite is true in human cells
so um
so
so we were sort of cautiously
starting to get excited but uh we really
didn't know
um
you know if it would work in in
mammalian cells and so then he started
trying in mammalian cells and his first
experiments were all complete failures
zero percent editing not even 0.5
percent editing
and uh
and you know andrew very quickly
figured out what changes in the system
were needed to get it to work in
mammalian cells and then i remember in
one monday subgroup meeting
people walk into my office every monday
we
everybody in the lab uh presents in
alternate mondays so everyone presents
every other week of what what they've
been up to what problems they've
encountered what uh results
it's positive or negative uh they've
garnered over the past couple weeks and
uh the lab helps brainstorm ideas for
what to do next how to fix problems et
cetera
and as we were walking in
as the students were walking into my
office that monday
one of the students
looked at me as he walked by and said
you are going to freak out
which is usually a good a good thing to
hear before one of these meetings
uh
and and you know i said oh why and he
said because andrew has data mammalian
cells
and so andrew presented the first prime
editing data in mammalian cells and you
know it was very modest it was a few
percent editing but the fact that we
could now install transversions and
insertions and deletions for the first
time at targeted sites in mammalian
cells was
uh was electrifying and uh
and uh just
caused a sort of buzz in the group
and an excitement and all sorts of
brainstorming about what to do next
uh that was you know probably unlike
anything i've seen in the 22 years i've
been a professor
sure i i bet it does i'm and in
particular i think the most remarkable
thing about the prime editing design is
the fact that you extended the guide rna
and so
the guide rna not only contained the
primer site for the refresh
transcriptase but it also contained the
desired edit changes and so what that
meant is you didn't need to introduce
donor templates that had the side edit
and so in many ways you kind of
simplified the system as well
right and and uh you know one of the
several things that had to work out in
order for it to be successful is so as
you point out there's a primer binding
site that has to complement the nicked
dna strand so that it aligns the nicked
dna strand here
so this part is that
use my youtube uh use my uh my zoom here
so this part is the primer binding site
here's the nick dna strand and then the
rest of my right hand
is the reverse transcriptase template
and so
this structure has to align and reverse
transcription then goes in this
direction to copy the edited dna
sequence directly into the target dna
strand of the mammalian of the human
cell genome
however
this primary binding site here
therefore mathematically must complement
the
spacer part of the guide rna the guide
rna still has to do its main job of
programming the crispr protein
to engage the target dna site and so the
primer binding site is complementary to
the spacer which means maybe all that a
peg rna a prime editing guide rna would
end up doing is forming
a sort of stem loop
so that was you know one of the
the
risks and and indeed we found that you
have to be very careful how long that
primer binding site is you make it too
long
even though normally polymerases love
having lawn primer binding sites because
it provides a bigger runway to more
stable runway to initiate dna
polymerization in this case prime
editing is all about
walking
the line between a variety of boundary
conditions and threading that needle so
that
you can initiate these molecular events
without
going
without forming structures that and
would ultimately be non-productive so
the primer binding site has to be of a
moderate length long enough to support
reverse transcription but not so long
that it ends up impeding the spacer
anyhow so all of that ended up actually
working out and
after some
improvements and a lot of testing in
lots of different
gene sites and in different cell types
uh we reported prime editing at the end
of
of 2019 and it's been subsequently and
then of course shortly thereafter
everything shut down because of the
pandemic
but our lab and others have uh continued
to use and advanced prime editing and
now
there have been a number of improvements
some of which have been published by
their labs others of which
we
hope to report this year
that
following in the footsteps of base
editing that have advanced prime editing
towards
broader and broader applicability
and greater and greater efficiency
and you know one thing that i think the
roughly 30 or so prime editing papers or
preprints that have already been
published
seem to
point to is the dna specificity of prime
editing really does appear to be
very high
higher than that of traditional crispr
uh gene editing
platforms because probably the in order
for the prime edit to actually take
place
watson quick based pairing has to occur
not just between the spacer and the
protospacer
the spacer of the guide rna and the
protospace or the target side of the dna
but also of the primer binding site and
the nicked dna strand
and then
downstream between the three prime flap
and the original dna strand so there's
three different checks on
dna hybridization
on sequence fidelity
that each serve as an opportunity to
reject an off-target sequence and we
think that's why prime editing is
has now been uh observed in multiple
labs to be
uh extremely dna sequence specific
this has definitely an added benefit
then right
um and as well um at least in the
original prime editing paper to as you
said with base editing one of the
problems is you end up with a mismatch
right where one strand's got the edit
and the other one doesn't and so you
want to kind of bias the cell to choose
the strand of the desired edits and the
way that you did that was by having a
secondary cast 9 complex that induced
the nick like a bit downstream and so
have you find ways um obviously the
concern with that is that you've now got
a nick in two places which could cause
a staggered double-stranded break which
is something that you would maybe kind
of want to avoid and so have you found
ways of circumventing that um would that
be an issue in terms of being able to
translate prime editing to the clinic
yeah so if you nick that bottom strand
you do increase prime energy and
efficiencies but you also increase in
dell levels
intel levels are generally with that
doubly nicked
version of the prime editing system
are generally higher than that of base
editing but with still favorable ratios
of editing to in bells so it might be
for example you get 30 prime editing and
you know eight percent in dells or
something like that
so we have
improved that aspect of it in a couple
ways which we hope to report this year
one is we have identified
some of the
uh the proteins that are implicated that
are involved in the prime editing
intermediate advancing and resolution
and have manipulated those proteins to
favor the desired outcome
and
that
tends to increase primating efficiencies
uh in many cases to the point that you
don't need the bottom strand nick
anymore to get sort of therapeutically
relevant levels of prime editing
even in some therapeutically relevant
cell types
like t cells or or primary patients uh
certain kinds of primary patient cells
um
uh also we have uh
uh developed variants of
i'd say you how to use the we've become
better at how to use the prime editing
system
to
uh program that second nick
so that it only occurs after the first
strand has been repaired
which minimizes the coincidence of
having two nicks
and then finally we've also
gotten better at choosing where to nick
where to put that second nick
so that it minimizes the chance of
that the tunics turn into a
double-stranded break nicks occur all
over your genome uh quite frequently
it's estimated that um you know
at any moment uh there might be
uh hundreds if not thousands of mix in
your genome uh
so the the trick to avoid turning nicks
into double-stranded breaks if they're
on opposite strands is to make sure that
the knicks either never occur at the
same time or if they do occur at the
same time they're far enough away that
there's plenty of watts and great base
pairs to hold the double helix together
and and to avoid having the ends come
apart into a double-stranded break
so it's a it's a great question and uh
there are i think a number of approaches
that
some publish some not yet reported that
improve that aspect of prime editing
you